here we are it's Jim Norton and Sam
Roberts Ricky and Ricky Gervais Sam Bert
Kreischer what a room I almost said Bert
Convy I swear to God I was thinking of
Bert Convy yeah we never be the most
famous Bert Bert Kampfer who's that I
don't know every time I Google myself he
comes up Ernie oh yeah oh yeah
especially after last week all the
controversy around are they are aren't
they yeah it's enough there's another
Jim Norton he's an Irish actor he's old
he's planning his late 60s or 70s but he
did have mice and men on Broadway so
he's getting all these people gonna
urine of mice and men you know he [ __ ]
up like stuff that's automated like IMDB
or like people have sent their radio
displays or podcast displays that just
look up Jim Norton and put your photo
we've done it with him
can you imagine but I can see it in a
few years time though that's good
respectable you start wearing a shirt
and tie but can you imagine being him
and seeing my googa like I get to see
[Laughter]
he's looking up like your book covers no
your published author he's got to be
[ __ ] miserable every time I use my
name come up Sam Roberts must be a
common name as well mostly yeah there's
a singer there's a Canadian singer
there's a New York Times writer there's
a there's a few that all have far more
respectable crafts than I do which isn't
you know unshaven but actually looks
good what would have to come Jesus
Christ to your point yes Sam Roberts is
a common name sure there any other Ricky
Gervais sir I don't know there must be a
law school them there must be he'll come
up first your baby now you're gonna see
some photos take the piss out of these
two just in quote to it yeah
no good images our images yeah [ __ ]
sake oh this is asking for isn't it oh
they're not bad
lesbian Jimmy Fallon in the middle
that's true really are was happy yeah
you know you can tell you've
accomplished a lot that you're the photo
of you and those tiny little gold boxer
briefs is way down below it doesn't come
up first mister oh god it's a hairy pits
this is good right yeah now we're all
just looking at pictures as you as Derek
and there's you with your arms out a lot
of happy pictures you look pretty good
now I'm and David Bowie Bowie young
where's the Bowie picture just he's gone
past it there is oh that's a nice shot
but look look at me young look at that
in a suit there with the skinny yeah
exactly
with the yeah yeah yeah you never want
to be someone your Grindr profile young
Ricky was going to be a sexy musician
you know and that what happens time just
does what it does to you and you go you
know what maybe I'm a comedy gonna be a
lead singer too yeah I kicked out I was
in a band in college called given I'll
spankings you a giving or given given
given out spank others with an
apostrophe yeah and then I kicked out
the guitarist and he formed creed oh
that's right yeah I think I know a story
I didn't realize it was called given out
spankings giving out spankings wait a
few names I mean ever really got out of
the garage but whatever what was your uh
what was your best original song this is
a song called Mary Margaret I wrote it
about hope about date rape I was trying
to be [ __ ] deep at the time was it pro
or con
it went little sister oh don't you walk
out of the door to make sure the so
called Jerry buyer what was the bandana
blaim I ain't lyin I know [ __ ] had a
song oh yeah that of crazy songs like
haha you got that right right that was
just a mental dismantle which you'd
expect better from them no David is
really anti day trip the the sublime
song sublime well you're like an artist
with a message yeah I would have
definitely gone down Fred Fred Durst's
path of mashing up hip-hop and rock I've
been I with my brain I can see that yeah
see that if you've got that vibe about
you because I tell you why because the
songs I did seriously are more
embarrassing than the songs I do as
David Brent so [ __ ] cringy I bet I get
a lump in my throat
not like Jim just awful pretentious
comedy pretentious electronic not the
name of one that you're embarrassed but
with the name of on the is the title of
a song I can't do it because it with the
hell I don't know what to do I can tell
you the ones that are released as well
with it's shown are dancing and they're
not too bad more to news it was quite
little day and you know but not about
the one that you were thinking which one
were you think of that you like I was
the most embarrassing song I've ever
written
oh I was one song called Johnny Wright
and it would chill me it was about being
in a band right oh god it was things
like what Johnny wants to do is buy a
set of wheels or to join a sleazy band
and he wants to die against a tree [ __ ]
but why die against the true cuz it was
rock and roll it was it retrying
god is that what you want then what's
that buy a car in the repression was or
were you Johnny better to take the
cardigan off why if they're wrong one
that's a real rock and roll dream he
thought it was better to burn out than
to fade away
yeah Johnny was gonna play with me we
did it was after the band that we're a
bit of success and then we did this song
and a few other equally awful songs
right a but you know rock and roll songs
right all this loads no I can't actually
can't think of it that's the one that
was our best one that's why I can
remember it's the story about Johnny so
Johnny wanna do is why say it was a join
the sleazy band he was divided against
the tree
he wants to OD in LA he just gets sick
and catch the plague oh right
and they're playing HIV reference very
socially conscious about 1986 does he
wanna does he want to [ __ ] died in a car
accident or an OD from the tree what
does he give it to the truck he's just
made foundation on heroin driving in the
trees underground bow alright by the way
the fact that he bought a couple cars at
least one is okay the other one last up
against the treatment of those cars fine
he caught the plague you hit a tree
right I like okay because it makes
people know like what would I have to
done for you to go [ __ ] me that's a
great song let's see gypsy lady exactly
that's why
red songs a bet because as a there's an
ironic get out quality street I'd become
more obsessed I went back and keep
listening today but you know what it's
about time that somebody pointed out
that in 1986 nades really was the new
play it's like it's like cuz you go like
this the plagues not around anymore
doing look at this he's found a sponsor
oh well this is nicer all this can you
get Ricky Gervais hit you grew up - we
can't hear it it wasn't a hit let's hear
[Music]
it's nice okay that really does sound
slightly influenced by the cure yeah but
this is not bad it's not bad it's good
chair meets boat well here's this I
guess I could see ninth grade me being
into this yeah this is by 85 yeah the
intense look in that photo I didn't know
you were [ __ ] draw I mean this isn't
just the Internet is that it doesn't
count it's not it didn't happen but
that's what makes the character David
Brent running to be a rock star so
amazing there's a thing in the film in
the life on the road that actually
happened I was in a band it was about
1986 and it was cool it was a place for
the bullying gay we're in a terrible
band called something like sacred hearts
I think there was that that one it's
cool soundcheck and the Rope said oh you
might as well stay up there you're on I
said when they open the doors
he went they're open no one's come to
see you so the band just look [ __ ]
crestfallen as I was in charge and I
went I said let's treat this as a free
rehearsal and we just did eight songs a
free rehearsal yeah I was trying to
sound positive yeah I mean you're right
they the promoter obviously no one
turned up to see it was well you know
you easily had different bands on their
concert and he felt so sorry for me that
you gave me ten pounds it was like the
most it was just like the probably the
lowest ebb what time do the doors open
they're open yeah no one's come through
oh okay
well least you have to worry about
making enough money to afford two cars
and driving one of them into a dream
yeah honey can't afford the heroin
that's gonna give him HIV you know I
love because I think that's where the
comic the Spirit comes is when you
trying to be serious tragedy of course
oh yeah being serious is is awful do I
walk into I walked into our band
practice one
time and they were playing a u2 song
that I didn't had never heard and I was
like this is good and I was like guys
this is really good we should do this is
amazing and they're like you think it's
like yeah and they're like you should
like a boombox
and I would play it for people so I was
like I was like the lyrics aren't
totally dialed in yet but this she's
lovely
yes she's lovely and met my buddy Obi
sat in a car with me one day and he goes
are you
are you joking with me and I was like
what do you mean he goes is this are you
Joe like joking with everyone I was like
no it's a great song she was like do
this the [ __ ] u2 song and I was like
what and then he played the u2 song I
was like oh my god so bad yours open
eyes Oh mine was about going through the
forest with a knife on your side Maya
Angelou I know the Caged Bird drinks did
you know anything about going through
the forest with a knife on your snow is
a rhythmic love was the one that had the
knife on his side was going through the
Lowell of love was going why does love
have a knife because love's been a good
lunch in gym love life why does love
have enough fair enough yeah yeah yeah I
mean that's really what we're always
loved love doesn't want to get hurt yeah
love why do you love have to fight like
this see James got away to this right
he's got nothing embarrassing this past
because what could compete with what we
already know about him with a pro you
could run for Congress and it would all
come out and people go yeah we know but
I wrote when I did the bearing from me I
wrote a poem okay
now we're now we're [ __ ] talking it
was real I put up my first book it was
it was a very very bad poem and Kevin
Smith read it on the air so it was so
humiliating I was in rehab was 1986 so
it was about it was about that was it
about Knicks are you terrible I it says
that words so this is how do I find this
thing it's in it's in happy ending
like I don't have a copy of my own book
I'll get your copy when I find it I have
to get a copy
Travis do we think we're gonna find a
guitar because either because this is I
really I at least want to hear birds pro
or anti date rape song okay I don't know
all the lyrics fine I remember the court
I'm sure okay by the way by the way it's
a little bit of a ripoff of the Indigo
girl okay right well luckily they mean
they held up fine
that's amazing I love the idea of your
mates going let's do it they know it's a
you would have me they would have me
read clubs really into poetry at the
time I'll go through a divorce and they
would have me read my poems at parties
and I thought that they liked them I was
like I would sit there and I'd start
with my poems and then I remember the
girls I mean we're talking like 50
people in a living room I love this guy
can you remember any poetry no the those
two those two will became the songs so I
don't remember I was really heavily
influenced by Maya Angelou what's the
moment I mean with everything that you
go through what's the moment when you
realize the band it's not gonna this
isn't gonna pan out this isn't gonna
work
well the first one we were sort of
dropped because we've got an advance and
we to put our two singles it didn't work
then you hang around and you do bands
well you've put out two singles yeah
yeah but we didn't even gig so it was an
electro I think so it was it was that
was a nice easy ride if you know what I
mean and then you go where let's do it
properly and you put band together you
go out and tour and you're playing to no
one and and then you know things happen
like we've got to get rid of this guy
I've gotta get with it we know when you
when you say oh we're breaking up the
band then you start it again without one
member or some food drinking or drugging
or are you just [ __ ] there terrible
no no what do you mean they're getting
rid of the guys they [ __ ] up with
someone new someone better see nothing's
like that
you know sometimes someone's so good in
the band you start a coup d'etat to get
rid of them so they don't like that
those guys that I still know in the band
they take the piss out of me because I'd
go up to someone in the street and I'd
say is that a guitar and they go yeah oh
you want to be in a band and they turn
out when the other guys Road
you can't blame
by the Tuesday phone oh we got my thumb
one I thought the King and I in our man
along would be great when it would be
fine right and it was just it and then
you realize that's not going to happen
quite soon and then instead of going
right that there's nothing on the edge
or let's do this properly I thought
there must be one idiot company out
there that will sign us I was like to
try and a con record companies into
signing bad and then that didn't work
and and I started I actually stopped
when I got a proper job when I realized
you know I thought I could do both but
you think now then you're not you're
then the job is actually paying the
bills and then you're like exactly and
you have a good time you don't want to
do it and it's it's again I think I
think like 29 I was embarrassed to be
trying to make it 29 but you kind of kid
yourself at first you get the job cuz
you're like I got to bring some income
in but this is just for the cash and I'm
gonna have to ban I allow me to do the
banding make you money now I remember um
there was a a big horse race when I was
a kid and one of my nieces or nephews
and put some money on the horse at the
Grand National summer and they won and
they would go crazy they won right and
my mum said that's the worst thing that
could've happened right and I got signed
so easily a knowledge it was easy and
then you think well I could I can do it
again and you can't it was you know I
mean it's a crazy thousand-to-one shot
and you can't even you're yeah yeah yeah
well yeah why is it a bad thing to win
and then you get a dick entire [ __ ]
happen guy who's the college doesn't
study and they gets discovered by
Rolling Stone magazine right it goes
[ __ ] it I'll just be a comedian right
well yeah but then you go then you think
actually it's instead of learning
experience everything's you know I mean
yeah it's funny that that my David Brent
funnier just the right just this this
best line though my favorite line was
when in the Christmas special when
Gareth was trying to you I didn't even
top the crack the top hundred didn't
want it to best line easily is when the
when they're going back and forth about
how to interact with customers there's
been a rape yeah just trying to win this
is all about showing off isn't it
narcissism and and I said it's Evan said
comedy is an ordinary guy trying to do
something that we all know he's not
quick to do right and that's us trying
to be rock stars in retrospect right and
we've all been that guy it's just so
relatable everybody in life at some
point thought they were gonna do
something this is brilliant and but you
do other you do other things like you're
a stand-up comic aren't you thanks what
you do and this is is this fun and pays
the rent sure that's right I love this
yeah it was always stand-up was always
where I want I know and it doesn't it's
not detrimental at all to stand up but
some people trying to be a stand-up and
they do some really awful and you know
target profile and it doesn't mix
whereas this is this is still in the
ballpark yes still your demographic yeah
and you always find people like when
they're looking for an excuse like for
me that's Jim doing this so actively and
stand-up so actively kind of points out
because there have been lots of people
that I've interacted with the start and
stand-up
not going so well then they do radio and
they're like oh I'm gonna do both and
they do exactly what you did where it's
like I don't really do stand up anymore
because I do more radio well it's and we
all know it's also about deception that
because people I think particularly in
Britain they they don't believe a
Renaissance man they think will choose
one of them because you can't be good at
all for even if you are or you know they
and it's what they've it's their
perception of what you do I know
stand-ups like do like reality game
shows but it kills them because people
go right he's not a stand-up well didn't
you know that you did your podcast after
the office
exactly did that leg did people go like
what I guess the acting's all dried up
well no because the podcast is it sneaks
it's not on television it's not
advertised it sneaks into your ears you
have to find it it's not like people
going oh this is a podcast that you know
because I'm on telly for something else
so a comedy on acting has always been
that whatever I've done has always been
the dominant thinks they know I mean
everything I've done is in the ballpark
you know I mean right but it is
dangerous like I'm like people I know
that have done a film they said it
killed the ticket sales it was a film
that wasn't I wasn't being comedy I was
known for this thing and they thought
well he's an actor because it became
more famous than them doing the circuit
right so there was nowhere to go so he
did some of this you know it so it's
gonna be tough for you after you all
your massive success in comedy to go
back and sing your songs about Johnny
yeah I was trying to talk about anything
just to get you off the scent right and
I started talking bollocks
and I thought they'd forgotten the
[ __ ] the truth is that there are so
many people that go out there and they
get the plague I mean you just end up up
against the truth you think you're going
in you want to buy it's like Bert always
says and if I ever have a daughter it's
how I'm gonna raise her if you go out
with a guy you got to make sure he's
okay yeah love carries a knife it's not
a poem night while I mean how did your
Coleridge it what how long is that I
know my god it rhymes like it's a tree
does it's a grade-school boy I was 17 oh
that's cold
I love I wish I had some of the books
that I
when I was like 14 15 right because I
got all off luck like cop shows so I
wrote one that was called dumb jezik I
made up the name jezic yes it was really
it was a hard New York cop who lost his
wife for drinking right what do you know
about New York anyway so it's just it
was just wonderful and a Jenny who's
drinking and his wife left
yeah well it's New York until until
someone kidnapped his door skills it
went off the Rosi [ __ ] took the law
into his own hands
no yes with your robe where the [ __ ]
rules in the first place maybe that'd be
a lieutenant didn't like him either
and that was like I'd feel a
exercise-book of this story that was
doing it right and I was saying people
I'm writing a novel right I even like a
teacher that read it in that and of
course they were horrified and they did
one called The Legend of Jodi Barnes
okay so a guy named Jodi yeah right no
right so this guy right he's only easily
14 right and these outlaws come and they
kill his family his family and needing
on the grave looking up and going I will
avenge thee right so he goes he goes to
the store and he gets some oka boys a
gun right and he gets all these bullets
and the guys goes and the guy goes
sheesh who are we at war with about any
practices
wine no she's just like that's the movie
trailer
who would sell a gun and dozens of
bullets to a fourteen-year-old West what
was his answer I have to know and he
didn't say anyone he's went and
practiced right and I was gonna find the
guys that you know it was just it but
I'm not gonna spoil it for anyone get
this commission oh my god watch it
Jezza is just a hard [ __ ] drinking
hard drinking cop right he lives alone
what he's lost his wife and his kid
right but yeah he's just he doesn't play
by play by the rules he does play with
the rules oh yeah yeah so coming soon
we've had for vengeance yeah I probably
plug in things that I've actually done
as opposed to well before we do try to
just get copies of Jeff's poem is that
what you got if you could pass them out
if you could pass them out to the room I
don't need a copy it's in here I'm
pointing my heart and we're where we
have at the guitar I mean we're a we're
not gonna use the guitar right radio
company I gotta hear bird song I wrote I
wrote a very serious novel in college I
was a creative writing major about a dog
who turns human right in and and is
basically misery but he locks up his
owner cuz his owner hasn't been good but
yeah back I kept saying voila in the
book like the dog kept saying voila
that's how he got it but spell check T
miss viola and it was so confusing to
everybody what is this a string
instrument have to do it I think you go
what string in dog who says voila
how many kids no and they could talk and
stuff and didn't work sounds good
forget it Jim it didn't take off oh okay
I just read one line of Jim's poem you
wrote in rehab right and it is one of
the douche okay I can't read it because
I can't read but gone okay I'm gonna do
you want me to read you Jim how'd you
like to read it I've already read
actually can we get the guitar and sing
it when waiting for the guitar guitar I
will have
riki singer he sings it I'll play it I'm
gonna read it so I'm while I'm stalling
for the guitar okay um this is it's
called the ode to some old friends yes
Ricky who do you think the old friends
are keep in mind jugs yeah oh yeah it's
a booze gym it's a combination of the
old friends yeah yes you're 17 and newly
sober I was sober yeah I was 17 it was
January of this this is around the time
the Challenger exploded that's when I
was in rehab for the January of 85 I
though our 86 early 86 is this should we
be taking the piss out of annex addicts
poem yeah after he's good I put in my
book it was so here I found this gym
sober yeah who needs to start drinking
again
correct it go hmm here I'll a Princeton
house just staring at the ceiling did I
put that I've laid put here I lay
without in that's amazing says here I'll
a Princeton house I don't know what this
train school I actually liked it the way
it rest
that's good yeah I didn't was a real
yeah these are they Princeton house we
have to break just we're doing between
these walls they've taught me how to
deal with all my feelings it's pretty
good kid was inside between the walls
this is when somebody first learns what
rhyming is saying great all right yes I
hid my pain down deep inside I tucked it
all away now that must be he must mean
his penis that that's right yes and
dancing round in front of the mirror
taking his fingers and trying to hide
his Adam's apple
yeah the pain it grew it ate at me it
killed me day by day was soo sad I had a
friend he helped me Coco [ __ ] named
Johnny Walker is a haiku just a series
of hydrogen
I haven't paid
like it's it's deducted a yeah yeah yeah
nice yeah oh my god way way way I'm
gonna start because this versus oh I had
a friend he helped me cope named Johnny
Walker red it hurt inside to learn the
truth he'd rather see me dead that was a
very unpleasant truth when my friend had
turned on me I didn't know how to handle
it oh my god yeah what is her more
thematic I think I see where you're
going somatically oh my god
you're just going against all the
brand's you're like Jack dang oh I
[Applause]
appreciate that Jack Daniels was another
one a so-called
friend of mine I'm not necessarily proud
of this next line although it's true to
life and I wrap my lips around his neck
he'd leave me feeling fine so did you
juice to drink out the bottle is that
what you're saying I did yes it was very
honest there was no lies in this poem
okay wait wait what it says he was his
friend but oh no sir more Jack Daniels
two had lied to me oh I'd been deceived
again so I set out in desperate hope to
find a loyal friend Wow
okay was he going to look different on
this radio show depressed no more my
spirit sword I was no longer sad okay
yeah do you want to read it out it hurt
no for I soon met a southerner by the
name
old granddad yeah yep I read by the
entire 9/11 Commission the whole book
the big thick book this lines the worst
thing I've ever read yeah that's bad dad
yeah and dad yeah what's the name of
alcohol is it certainly I believe a
southern with you getting the motif of
this now I'm starting to see oh my my
favorite part of that whole thing was
just hearing the background what do you
think Oh God so all we then 17:17 oh
that's good in rehab 17 yeah could you
stand up in front of the whole Reno know
what I did was worse it's more
humiliating what I actually did was I
wrote it and then I left it out and then
if people found it and they were like
everyone was talking about like who
wrote this poem and I was just quietly
basking in it I was sitting around
trying to start conversations about the
poem this is the best and by the way by
the time I finally confessed that I
wrote the poem no one cared no one gave
a [ __ ] he keeps going oh I was coming on
yeah he led me to the promised land the
road we'd start to pave but the only God
but the only road this bastard knew was
a shortcut to the grave good night I was
very hurt to learn that no yeah I would
I would like I would like to pay money
to be able to find a time travel to go
back and see Little Jimmy Norton with
his cowlick on feet dangling off the
side of the bed riding and going short
to the grave like the excitement when
you came up with the rhyme yeah tell me
what you don't like I had I was young
Jim Norton notes it's aggressive look I
have I had a Calif I agree we use sort
of like a you know apart from the
suburban angst yeah but you like will
you talk were you tough guy were you
like no certain that's a good ones grow
up that's that's my first headshot
that's 92 Wow the the the high student
Opera
picture oh yeah it just thought that's
might me as a junior in high school well
and go to me is that go too despicable
that's me is a such mice mice [ __ ]
sophomore picture in high school well
one we you are you're great
yeah and I've not some mice or what
years that then the one with the haircut
I want to say sophomore year was
probably 84 i want to say 84 because I
wrote this year that's me Jeffrey Dahmer
ish as a voice is incredible
that's 17 right there that's amazing
family yes otherwise it'd be weird there
were regular glasses yeah but they did
have a tint to them which the light
would bring on and so what's already
there 17 so when he wrote this that's
about the age yeah
and so how quick was it you started
drinking at what I it's not 13 oh we're
very young and so and were you diagnosed
we just a drinker and a tear away
or were you are you an alcoholic and you
I knew it was a problem right on I knew
early on and my dad is sober so I knew
it was a big problem and I drank for a
year after that I stopped when I was 18
right great I started when I was 18 did
you yeah and a lot of people did I was
sizing the IT team yeah I didn't want to
drink oh I think that I didn't I thought
well did you not want to drink or do so
scared of it what happened to Jessica
[Laughter]
you really thought that was gonna be a
real conversation
I did a joke once right it was um I've
been sober for 18 years the first
eighteen years I've been drunk ever
since right and then this paper that
slow Christmas but I think I've been
drunk ever since I was 18 and pictures
of me at parties drinking like it was
some sort of [ __ ] confession it was a
judge is a one lot as true you're
implying me never drank everything right
yeah right [ __ ] now
do you read the rest of this Punk yeah
okay this is tough this is like this is
worse than therapy oh it's bad I found
this I forget where it was when I found
it I did a photo of it in my book like I
took a photo people knew I wasn't
writing it now yeah and I just in red
ink wrote things ever oh that's great
yeah and it's a oh that's grand was
unkind I left these friends not knowing
that my end was drawing near quite sheep
thought I to leave the Rye that gin and
Everclear
by the way I'll confess this quite sheep
thought I I stole from Clockwork Orange
I did guess it's better than Maya
Angelou okay I'd be okay quite shape
though I yeah sheep thought I Alex said
that in Clockwork Orange right I put
quite because it worked for the poem it
didn't work Jim I thought quite helped
you but I'd been tricked and my disease
would look at me and sneer but this
social drink oh you missed out lying
goddamn it I'd be okay if every day I'd
stick to only beer but I'd been tricked
and my disease would look at me and
sneer but this quote social drink made
glamorous by commercial on TV always
blaming the fake coal fresh in support
always old [ __ ] Bill Hicks it's just
funny it's just from these little
[ __ ] 17 year old device right right
commercials on TV would take its toll
I'd sell my soul
it was my enemy right you know a lot of
commas
I knew not why Rick your coffee sure
coffee or tea thank you oh I knew not
why I couldn't find a friend who'd
really help but then I knew my time was
here it was time to help myself
we're almost done we're almost through
it
my mind was sick my body scarred my life
was at its low I thought it was but
light shine through the Princeton house
like a fire in the snow probably a
better way to say light shining through
yeah and this one is just a lie I'm
happy now my life is good and hope is
shining in it was a lot of lies but the
worst part of this mad disease is that
to surrender means to win I don't get I
don't get it either you don't need to
get it yeah the surrender is to win some
art is just what does that mean you mean
surrender to the bottle service no but
if you know that you I will answer the
question there's no defense of my
phrasing just cuz you have to surrender
do you have to just go I've lost that's
it right okay good yeah we do have a
guitar this is just the worst
him no me yeah no and you knock knock
teams we'll see how we all feel after
Bert doesn't would you see I don't know
you never know maybe no no no do do
Ricky I can't do Ricky I can't I'm not
as brave as Jim I'm not brave you guys
read it I couldn't have read this yeah
you're gonna play you a song about well
I thought we were gonna do some of your
originals
no what if I marry what if I embarrass
myself what you do and then you guys
feel better about yourself what are you
gonna do show up on shaving
[Laughter]
try to chew back a wiggle I'm surprised
that Jim I hasn't remembered because
he's heard it before that's right
do you think it's appropriate I forget
what it is but I remember he wrote a rap
he did a rap original song then Jim you
read from your poem you say respond to
one right ok ok alright we are done this
is gonna be nice
[Music]
comment
oh it's really nice to start what Johnny
wants to do is buy a set of wheels of to
join a sleazy band and he wants to die
against a tree but he just crashes in
his room dies on stage and stumbles home
what Johnny wants to do that's enough
poor Johnny I want to know I was
grinding my teeth so bad what happens
you know why when you go he's johnny on
the spot and you didn't realize that was
a porta potty now that you remembered
some of the lyrics can you start from
the beginning and maybe go a little bit
further just so that we have for
posterity you know we should have it
yeah we should we should have fun yeah
and let's everybody it's good okay guys
[Music]
oh yeah what what Johnny wants to do is
make a guitar sing the blues I don't
remember the next [ __ ] ow Jane Jane I
I have the Ricky's entire support team
behind him is all like making the exact
same faces we are like oh my god yeah
his publicist just quit with Ricky can
you start from the beginning so we can
get everything in college I mean this is
a whole picture here with Johnny's in
his room the whole thing happened is we
don't remember the tree part can we
start from the beginning yeah okay
what's the beginning this is literally
the worst right right at the beginning
what yes I really don't remember that
next bit is there anything we can chorus
in with you
like okay yeah we can get a full verse
in and maybe singles with chorus it
doesn't there isn't one okay good
perfect it's this one it's too serious
yeah that's true there's no time for
chorus abandon he he a pen and paper to
die against a train but he just stumbles
home good
he won't still OD in LA they just got
sick and catch the plague okay all right
sing it now you know now look at my form
okay cuz it's actually a pretty good
song oh [ __ ] it is actually Santa PEZ I
thought what Johnny wants to do if I
said I know that's wrong in it already
what was the first by the energy is
right yeah the energy is right I think
what to do I think by I said it we also
say that that's the way I know yeah it
makes the most sense how is he gonna get
from gate to gate because it starts that
tree what was it Oh Ricky taking me is
it about Kaepernick you got this ring
I forgot what I was a tree why does he
die against a tree he's going to get the
plague in LA yeah
digested prey no that's our that's
against the tree wait let's do what I
said it was a - he wants to OD in La
that's the second way through the tree
the tree this first one of the second he
wants to somebody wants to be join the
sleazy band and hey yeah yeah thievery
and he yeah yes yeah okay we're ready to
start from the beginning yes I'm gonna
discard that video that's a start right
what Johnny wants to do
it's by a set of wheels or to join a
sleazy band he wants to die against a
tree but he just crashes in his room
dies on stage and stumbles home watch
Johnny wants to do that's enough that
was really that was really something
special my special secret time on
Netflix okay now that was really
something special yeah I mean a lot of
times people like they hear the fun you
know silly side of Ricky Gervais but
nobody gets that sensitive science can I
be honest with the way I have to admit
massive failures is the thing that made
us fall in love with you that David
Brent character is every single one of
us and it really is inside of you and
that's what we had then that like did no
one could have played their kisses
stalling Rick no accolades sing at all
exactly oh stop kissing ass and let's
find out you know that's okay okay [ __ ]
I guess I can't do this nope nope nope
you got it from the top from the top
that's my poem they feel my pain
[Music]
I'm my [ __ ] neck from the top your
neck is fine I just started going in
getting [ __ ] yeah you go we're enjoying
enjoying oh hey sorry wow you had a
Facebook op as wow it's good
[Music]
little sister won't you look out the
door part of my mom's name's Mary
Margaret I did with that I wrote that on
I wrote that on a piece of paper I wrote
that song a piece of paper when we moved
out of our house in Tallahassee I was 21
I was 20 I was 21 because I just I was I
think I was 20 I think I was 23 or
somebody said we shouldn't name that
it's not even a 17 you know he's doing
this shitty poem yeah but we were
[ __ ] leave it should have been I took
that poem and I went into our closet for
that song I had written on a piece of
paper and there was a nail in our closet
and I pushed the paper onto the nail and
I thought the next person who lives in
here is gonna see that and go [ __ ] I
live in that house the house of my
biggest fear right now is I'm in therapy
but I do it on skype and I'm afraid that
I can't be totally honest in my therapy
because I'm afraid someone's on skype
and someone's gonna upload it and people
will watch me legit talks like oh that's
my biggest fear because I'm never I'm
never in LA that's illegal
that's against the law to hack into your
oh you mean for them to go for a doctor
to a doctor appointment like that no
affair that he has this toppity being
totally doesn't matter I've never done
therapy I don't know whether I'd like it
or not or where they were doing I've no
I have no idea I've you know I haven't
had like bad sort of a deals but uh yeah
um Skype is it is make me nervous I
think talk on the phone then I'm just
afraid someone it doesn't matter it's
like the Sony emails it doesn't matter
if someone puts it out there the right
thud and everyone's like yeah you know
let's talk about it and so I did this
thing but if something's out there it's
like oh [ __ ] yeah I know you mean yeah
they're like a connection to I feel like
your personal space
option.i yes yeah what'd you do tour and
do it like once a week or somewhere you
are I'll do it I'm always it I'm always
near and doesn't work out the way I
should have you have you know I go every
week they're tired of the game that's
not to do with it that's not to do with
this
this poem no better daddy probably not
to see me anymore can't help right yeah
I've been like here in there but not
regularly but it's a much much more
common in America isn't it everyone just
go yeah how do they do it well they do
but I mean paranoid talk about talk
about it much and I don't I don't think
it's got the infrastructure I mean we
have like you know addiction things in
that book no I think not like psychiatry
in that that's a you know someone has to
tell you to go people don't go oh I feel
a bit sad I'm gonna go to a therapist in
England you know it's like yeah it's not
it's not as easy I don't they're good
because they just ask you they make
slight observations read they cause you
to ask questions yourself a good
therapist doesn't run your life they
just kind of give you a little little
little nudge yes an intelligent person
who's not attached to you and what's all
questions with that or they just say how
are you feeling and then you go off on
it or they'll just take observations
about what I say or your wife will email
them and go hey bring this up to Birds
that's amazing anything she'll be like
like our she was one that got me in
therapy yeah had a spin out and I was
like and I was in a hotel room and I
just felt like I had no control over my
life and apparently I was getting PTSD
from riding roller coasters from my
birthday from my travels just like the
troops I got the fear of dying on a
roller coaster I've wired yeah I was
doing not just well because we're
skydiving and jumping out of like
jumping off bridges and do a lot of
times that happen to people who were in
Afghanistan and stuff like that but sure
rollercoaster yeah Vietnam vets
yeah that's it in there and they they're
scarred and they've got that you know
the no legs and that and you go here you
should see this big one yeah let's go it
went up slow but it came down real fast
I I know one time I went
Six Flags three weeks ago and it was I
get afraid of like Charlie and it's the
log flume for birth yeah taxes scary
scary too having to fight for your kind
of bean bean I in the second when you
had to go whether you wanted to or not
knowing you'd probably die right that
was pretty scary when it's on the front
look you know you go before me yeah he's
pretend to be too short right get on
he's still walking on his knees with
slippers John McCain when you met him
like I was on line one time it felt like
seven years
yeah cuz panic attacks you think you're
gonna die so it's almost as scary as
when you think you're gonna die cuz
there are enemies shooting at you and
all your friend I just died are you sure
I'm sure we're gonna get in trouble for
this show well great well we've taken
the piss out of addiction therapy post
my poem your poem yeah my [ __ ] Johnny
Johnny which is like a classic right now
bunch of our tree enthusiasts will be
angry I'm actually shaming until now he
was a band I was in and all the people
we played in front of I reckon about 78
people to turn that song that's enough
in it but where to plug oh yeah yeah
we're plugging Ricky shows called child
supports a new season it's Friday
October 5th it premieres 9 o'clock on
ABC and it's where you you you are the
kids are there 10 questions and they
have a 200 thousand dollars they can win
and they run into trouble there's a
roomful of five kids and you wake up in
the world
I just ask questions the kids are funny
they add it all together and then
someone else has to make the show good
it's good good fun
Netflix humanity that's it and also what
about your short show I
six-episode series on Netflix oh yeah
I've just finished editing at the moment
yeah but every next that me next let's
think about a life sort of a dark comedy
um
I play a guy whose wife dies and I'm
gonna think of killing myself but I
don't cause the dogs hungry and I feed
the dog it gives me time to think I'm
angry but um I'm gonna I'm gonna do what
I want from now and I'm gonna say and do
whatever the [ __ ] I want cuz I'm not
scared of anything anymore and then when
it gets too much I just kill myself I
think it's a superpower so I just starts
doing saying what the [ __ ] I want
yeah once the certainty of that is there
there's nothing else that matters
because you always that there's a
solution right yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that that's that that's the premise is
funny it sounds really twisted and up
but it is really funny but that's not
for ages okay yeah and watch watch some
life on the road on Netflix and see and
watch my real life but with a goatee
that's kind of you know what you you and
David Brent is exactly the same
relationship as Jim Norton and chip trip
person where everybody thinks that
they're looking at this character but
this is just Jim throwing up all of his
insecurities and being his true self on
stage yeah it really does it's a good
thing about stand-up isn't it you can
say what you want I love I love the fact
that there is there's there's no
interface you think of some what you can
say it and they hear it and write change
it every night I'm so excited I feel I'm
a stand-up now more than yeah do you get
nervous at all you know especially
homework
I can't wait what about what about like
the amount of people who aren't getting
[ __ ] for doing that like the adair you
know because every sets getting recorded
well they go [ __ ] they can take out our
context if they want but I don't think I
had a complaint from 800,000 people who
saw that show and those are net pics of
people don't like I don't say I don't
give a [ __ ] like and justify everything
I said it's not me going crazy and
trying to hurt people's feelings and
destroy society it's me making jokes but
I still stand by and if people don't
like it
what can I do what can I do has Netflix
given you any way I can restrain loved
it and they said it was a funny special
very funny special yeah yeah no I had
heard that Tom Segura your friend Bert
Kreischer and ours
ruin the r-word for everybody that was
the last of the r-word on Netflix [ __ ]
how didn't he I didn't hear that he
explained the joke is around the
word Oh [ __ ] yeah we talked about
that I think that makes me laugh that if
you say something you know and then it
then you know some people on the radio
discuss the joke I said well you're
discussing it and that's what a joke is
it's a very quick funny discussion about
off topic yeah
so what what harm can it do to discuss
it you know and and I don't and I don't
think I don't say I yeah I know it was
wrong I don't think it is wrong
everything I do I think is right and you
know I mean yeah totally anyway why
would you do why would I do it well
right there and just say things I don't
believe in or I don't agree with yeah
unless it's ironic which is again you're
saying the wrong thing the comic effect
to show the right thing assuming they'll
understand that you're beyond what can
you do because you wore it down too much
in what are you doing you're doing
[ __ ] awful hack anodyne [ __ ] that
everyone gets and no one cares about
right so I do want people to be this
clever to get on this ride do you not I
mean yeah so I don't bring him
rollercoaster reference back to a place
where we do have some music to play
though I think we'd moved out late
Travis did you find something
all right so I have Sam's very smart he
is I don't think he's ever given this to
any of us so anytime we've played it on
the air he's been in charge of it yeah
so all I have is on-air recordings of it
okay so Ivan I got but we were more
talking about like Ricky's upcoming
project yeah yeah I mean yeah well the
name of the it was called [ __ ] please
[Laughter]
the name you know Eminem was a big
rapper at the time yes he was I saw him
at the time sure there's probably a
nineteen you uh yeah yeah yeah and and
me and my other two friends who happen
to also be Caucasian we thought it'd be
funny to do like a funny rap group but
you know you can say this is just
supposed to be funny but we all were
like started by going like we'll just do
it as a goof and you can completely hear
when you listen to it we're going like
actually I think yeah so we
[Laughter]
or is this about drive from now on I
forgot the name of the room yeah it's a
take off you know
oh what's the name of the group junior
mint
oh my and then the your is why is it one
word you know this is actually labeled
incorrectly it's one word it's J Oh Oh N
why oh you are M
' nt tibideaux wasn't C ' NT suppose
you're trying to spell out can I do so
which which I don't know what what I
wish she was about a je w and June in
like three Jewish kids yeah June might
as well have been more integrity than
that quite frankly about a missile I
don't know which do you know what song
it is Travis it's that side as far as I
know it's the only one we've ever played
okay I don't remember not good yeah hey
drop a beat just get away now this is
time for revenge isn't it yeah do you
mind if I masturbate I don't think we
even need this I don't think we need to
play it yeah you know why yeah just how
long do you want to hear
I just just how long is their song it's
55 seconds I want to hear the first 53
that's a lot yeah
I think they just add it as freedom
[Music]
pause pause the hubcaps are you have a
bulletproof vest like this why why
hubcaps turn out what you want on a car
my rims
I'm sure eyes maybe seizures I don't
recall know you think you were a
gangster can you hear yourself objecting
to it in the original tape was I like
when you listen to it again you can hear
Jim in the background on oh yeah okay
but no I'm sure I be that brought up
singing with Elton John you know yeah
yeah you know you know as Eminem
you know yeah you remember yeah musics
at its best when you have to explain it
with the bulletproof vest apparently
there's gang activity in Europe target I
I don't stand by this anymore
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
Aston Kutcher sucks but Demi Moore sucks
but Demi sucks more and then Demi sucked
him off whatever it is Ashton and Demi
just have to replay really tight it
makes it tidies it up it's almost like
yeah let's hear that again because Sam's
really taking on Hollywood no way hold
on you're forgetting the fact that in
the middle goes on let me take that over
they do it again it's doing like that
yeah you just forgot off the dome with
it that's fake fourth wall breaking let
me start it all again I can handle a lot
my insides are in complete knots right
now I can't handle such a drone as well
is such a [ __ ] drug yeah yeah really
yes thanks I'm starting to wish we'd
never gone down this way all right a
little bit more tell us more about the
series that's coming out soon on Netflix
you're the dog yes you actually played
this song and if you can make it through
without killing yourself okay good well
this is this is like therapy this is
healthy yeah I'm gonna bring immediate
Lee yeah I'm gonna start that was really
bad yeah especially to get faster yeah
it's getting good to you yeah you know
this is actually double the flow yeah
you can tell that even though I was like
trying to mask it around your corner
quote yeah right humor I took great
pride in the fact that I could my
cadence could go that's like somebody
going watch me silly dance but they
really think they can do that this is
why I don't talk during sex because when
I show you that's part of me you're just
gonna laugh like so I don't talk to any
sides just realized that I don't talk
during sex because I'm great then I'll
say the thing like I'll be earnest I'll
be like say something that I think is
hot and sexy like why didn't it like
nothing about Turkey shut the [ __ ] up
this is place is worth what are you a
nurse than Johnny yeah no I need some
I'm very vocal and good I have to be
like what do you say what are you afraid
of trick I'm afraid of anything I say
the door it might be the place
yeah what do you say what are you
worried about saying blurt out no I'm
just afraid I don't speak at all I just
but what do you why don't you speak well
we want to say that why come out ahead
say something I feel like I'm gonna
throw up after yeah we all do would you
say yeah it was fine it was really good
[ __ ] Johnny okay we're in the bedroom
you and your wife you're in the air
you're going through very very rigid
rigid okay what are you saying what are
you saying
about 25 minutes we're almost there I
came early I get to leave early speaking
of speaking of my Ricky came early burn
go back to what something dirty like
this bursting like this ooh that's
nice and then one cap just makes me
uncomfortable leaving the idea but you
say that you like it when this is this
is I'll see if I have a good texture
egad yeah Jim you read one of your text
just to get burped on the mood can't
read a text Jim no these are two
teachers I hear that poem we just read
my wife window you'll Paul wife don't
pander to these two they like ghouls I
think you might be right I think you
should call your wife it wasn't him
you're on the air
hey what did you ask your wife oh my god
maybe they didn't hear it there's kids
in the car it was like you were calling
with your lawyer for an alibi if I've
ever spoken during sex okay we can top
that I'm going